der csu chef markus söder bayerns
ministerpräsident das nämlich reichlich
anders gesehen und her hat olaf scholz
und vor allen dingen seinem kollegen
armin laschet diesen satz mit auf den
weg gegeben wenn ein wahlergebnis das
kann man nicht uminterpretieren oder um
wünschen wie es ist ist zunächst mal so
das hat man zu akzeptieren das ist für
mich eine grundregel der demokratie man
muss auch jeder selber dann seine
verantwortung definieren die er dabei
hat
und auch schauen wie man daraus positive
energie ziehen kann meine aufgabe ist
das parteivorsitzender das mandat hier
war zunehmend für die csu dann auch wenn
sondierungsgespräche wenn mit alexander
dobrindt zusammen mal sehen welche und
überhaupt über das sicherlich wenn es
sondierungsrunden gibt nicht 2017
wiederholen endlose gespräche und pausen
auf den balkonen das glaube ich ist
nicht etwas was die leute begeistert hat
da waren sich schnell und zügig
entscheidungen gerade weil die
konstellation so knapp und instabil und
so viele partner beteiligt sind meine
aufgabe ist jetzt als parteivorsitz
alles andere ist
spekulation hier die glaube ich keinen
nährboden hat und ich habe es gelesen
alles ich kenne dazu nix kann nur eines
sagen die besten chancen kanzler zu
werden hat derzeit olaf schulz
eindrücken sack der saß der satz die
besten chancen kanzler zu werden hat im
moment olaf scholz er beschreibt eine
realität damit markus söder aber das
beschreiben der realität kommt bei der
union offenbar nicht gut an das ist im
moment teilweise sagst du philipp eine
andere welt absolut zumindest die welt
in der cdu chef armin laschet lebt
natürlich kann die union auch regieren
wenn grüne und fdp mit der union
regieren wollen aber man muss klar sagen
dass man der wahlverlierer ist man kann
auch als wahlverlierer regieren aber man
muss die harte realität erst einmal
aussprechen weil sonst kommt man da
nicht wieder raus andere abgeordnete
machen das wie zum beispiel die cdu
abgeordnete gitta connemann die gestern
ordentlich gas gegeben hat in dieser
fraktionssitzung in all ihre zitate sind
aufgrund seines handy angekommen absolut
gitta connemann hat ausgesprochen was
wirklich der fall ist und hat hat diese
diskrepanz kritisiert die es gibt
zwischen der parteibasis und dem partei
establishment sie hat gesagt dass die
parteispitze spricht davon dass es einen
regierungsauftrag gibt und die basis
spricht davon dass es eine historische
niederlage gibt die basis wollte immer
etwas anderes als die parteispitze in
den vergangenen jahren die basis wollte
friedrich merz einmal gegen ak und
einmal gegen armin laschet die basis
wollte auch markus söder als
kanzlerkandidaten und nicht armin
laschet und die parteispitze hat in
ihrer eigenen welt leben immer genau die
falsche genau die andere entscheidung
getroffen und die spiegelt sich jetzt im
wahlergebnis wieder wir leben in zwei
welten was für ein satz von der cdu
abgeordneten gitta connemann und gitta
connemann hat noch einen anderen satz
gesagt gestern in dieser
fraktionssitzung und der ging so wer
übernimmt denn hier verantwortung für
dieses wahlergebnis und zwar wann genau
ermutigung antwort fällt negativ aus
niemand nie also bislang weigern sich
die verantwortlichen verantwortung und
tatsächlich zu übernehmen angefangen
natürlich bei armin laschet der ganz
kurz bei einem presse statement gesagt
hat er wisse auch dass er eine
mitverantwortung trage eine mitschuld
trage an diesem schlechten ergebnis und
das werde man dann jetzt in den gremien
im ganzen land irgendwie aufarbeiten
aber es ist nicht nur er alleine schauen
wir uns mal wolfgang schäuble an der hat
sich gestern komplett bedecken hinhalten
seit der wahl klatsche er hat laschet
durchgeboxt als kanzlerkandidat aber
wenn es jetzt um verantwortung geht da
schweigt er er hat nichts beizutragen
genauso volker bouffier er hat schäuble
geholfen fundamental geholfen laschet
zum kanzlerkandidaten gemachten wo sind
denn die profis und die schäubles die
jetzt sagen leute das war falsch das war
wirklich falsch
[Musik]